all right we have our share of breweries
all over the valley but now las vegas is
getting into the wine business
pine hollow winery on charleston and
rainbow is now open and as mary jane
belliesa reports the owners are serving
the community through every sip
it's a refreshing new site in fiesta
square pine hollow winery is a new small
business in the west valley opening
their doors just last month making them
the first winery to open within las
vegas city limits and the seventh winery
to open in the state owner barbara d
virgilio and her husband john moved to
las vegas from the east coast three
years ago after seeing a need for more
wineries in the area western pa where we
were from there were wineries were
popping up you know
every other corner so we decided to
bring our unique wines to the west
because
there's nothing like us here all the
wine is prepared and made in the back
room and there's a little fix for
everyone for those who have a sweet
tooth and for those looking for some
spice we have a hot pepper wine it's our
niagara vine infused with a thai chili
pepper it's not for the faint of heart i
had one customer tell me that it was an
explosion in your mouth so that's what
we go with for that one
while the pandemic did delay the opening
of pine hollow winery it didn't slow
down the production of their wine as the
owners were still able to import grapes
from the east coast bringing a little
taste of home here to las vegas
although it took more than a year to
open virgilio says their patience and
hard work has made it all worthwhile to
cater to their customers needs and the
taste of dedication is clear to see we
were determined that we would not give
up we just rolled with it reporting from
charleston and rainbow mary jane balleza
live local now